hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and today I'm going to be
talking about my highlights for
September 2016 basically talking about
all the games and movies that I checked
out this month this one's gonna be kinda
short one compared to normal because I'm
actually pretty sick at the moment I
have a terrible cough and that's why I
have the hair of someone who has been in
bed sick for a day it's not great
especially when I have neo Comic Con to
go to next week and I'm DJing it gamer X
this Saturday it's not a good time but
that is a pretty good place to start I
am DJing the next two weekends in a row
I'll leave links below to the events for
that if you want to come hang one of
them is New York City so that's gonna be
my second time ever DJing on the East
Coast which I am super excited about and
it's full annual comic-con off the party
so it has been a super xbox II month
this month starting with bolsa horizon 3
I absolutely loved Forza horizon 2 and
my first thought when playing Forza
horizon 3 was after this how do they
make a fools arising for there is so
much to do everything looks beautiful
it has thoughts of physics so the causal
handle incredibly well including the
watt hog which is the best I think my
only complaint with Bulls in horizon 3
is that none of the tracks themselves
really stand out that much I think it's
moments that stand out in Forza horizon
more than actual tracks like by having
you race a helicopter or something
ridiculous like that so it's the scale
of it that appeals rather than the
actual tracks themselves or the way that
they're laid out there you might have
complained though if you have an Xbox
one and you haven't picked it up yet I
would definitely recommend checking it
out I think that's this weird thing
where even if you don't like ok races
you're probably going to love fulsol
horizon next up books the witness and
file watch came out on Xbox one
they were originally ps4 games and I
really like both of them at this stage
the witness is still my game of the year
I am positive that's going to change
with like he is full coming out in like
two weeks and titanfall and benefit 1
and Matthew 3 and what Stokes 2 and
Dishonored 2 and all of the awesome
stuff that's coming out for the rest of
this year but for the entire first half
of 2016 it is the witness but for those
who haven't seen anything of it it's not
like a page turner puzzle game you put
in this open
you have no idea what it is or what it's
about and they're just puzzles every way
that you can approach and they teach you
the rules as the game goes on but
there's no tutorial it's like you have
to figure out how it works and then
though the future puzzles that combine
two different things that you've want
and you have to like remember all of
these rules that you've been taught
throughout the course of the game
without any text I think that's what
makes it so impressive the witness is
hard and the witness makes you feel very
smart
Firewatch is a much shorter story driven
game that also came out on ps4 earlier
in the year I didn't like Firewatch I
think as much as most other people I
know did but it's still a really cool
short and very cheap experience it does
a good job of kind of tricking you into
not knowing what genre it is and it's
definitely not predictable and has some
very creative writing in there so if
you're not after super action games then
the witness and file which both awesome
and you should definitely check that out
Rico also came out this month and recall
is kind of a weird one because I feel
like it was a first b-grade game that I
can think of that came out this cycle
the ps3 and 360 era had like a lot of
middling games like games that were not
too hyped up people didn't expect the
world from them but were just kind of
nice surprises you know I'm talking
about games like Berto type and enslaved
which quietly is the best thing that
I've played this month came out six
years ago and I finished it yesterday
and I love it they're all really good
games that had smaller marketing budgets
so we didn't expect them to be amazing I
think that perspective kind of changes
how I feel about recoil but in general
yeah I was disappointed by Rico I think
it has a really nice world it has good
world building and I really like the law
and I like the characters I like the
main character I like the dogs
I like the customization options for you
little Robo buddies but the combat is
probably the biggest letdown for me it
is mostly just holding both triggers and
occasionally jumping at the start of the
game it is entirely just hold both
triggers
you don't aim because there's auto aim
so it's it doesn't really feel like
you're doing very much it does get to a
point where you have to cycle through
the face buttons depending on the color
of the enemy you're attacking I like
that in theory but when you
it's not really that fun I feel like
Rico is a game that probably would have
benefited from either having more to the
comment or just less combat in general
Rico also does have a hell of a lot of
loading screens which again makes them
feel kind of like 360 game if you go
into it thinking it is a b-grade game
and not a triple-a game I think that
your experience will be a lot better so
for movies this month the only one that
I actually saw was Blair which feel like
every single month when I do one of
these there's always going to be
something that has too much exposition
because that's a thing that Wright is
just always [ __ ] do this month it's
blow which there is a super annoying
thing that they repeat like four times
it's like yeah your camera has GPS just
make sure that you have battery or it
won't work you didn't need to tell me
that four times I'm also not going to
spoil anything when I feel like there
are parts of this that indicate that
they cut stuff out or edited stuff out
because some of the stuff that happens
doesn't lead anywhere
so some strange writing choices but as a
whole the premise is very cool there's a
lot of stuff that like loops they play
was time really creatively it kind of
plays with the premise of the different
dimension in a really interesting way
and I feel like the relationship
dialogue and this is very good
I believed that a certain couple of
dating I believe that they were good
friends they make jokes that real people
make which is nice to see in a horror
movie so while there was some things
that were very odd and [ __ ] the jump
cuts was so annoying the way they did
jump scares in this movie was by having
a jump cut with a loud noise if your way
of trying to scammy is by assaulting my
eardrums you're not doing a very good
job than scaring me and honestly I
didn't find it that scary as a whole but
the premise and and where it leads and
how it deals with are it leads is all
very very cool and it's something that
actually kind of happened in Austin free
which is a game that came out earlier
this year that you should also totally
play okay I am actually dying I will
leave links to both of those events that
I am DJing at below and also IGN is
having a birthday party on October 15th
that I'm not DJing yet but I will be at
so leave a link to that one below if you
want and also thank you to another
person who supported my channel which is
basically just like a fan donation thing
it's a thing that you want to do you can
see it on my about page on youtube as a
link to
thank you so much to Mathew dubbing us I
seriously appreciate it
you are best thank you okay I can't
breathe I'm gonna go pass out thank you
guys for watching I will see you on that
side boy